hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein typisch libanesisches
rezept ich werde aktiv machen und zwar
sind kleine gefüllte pfannkuchen und die
werden später mit sirup getränkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon die diskussion an
und die einen sagen nein das ist nicht
übermäßig das südarabische marokkanisch
also wir haben von unseren libanesischen
freuen
alles was ist in mehreren arabischen
kultur natürlich vertreten ist samira
schreibt de la estrella es ist ein ding
ein schwäbisches rezept weil das heißt
nicht beim spielerkreis es nämlich
sapperlot jedenfalls in das kleine
gefüllte pfannkuchen normalerweise
traditionell mit einer milch creme aber
wir werden heute einmal eine morath
variante und eine original variante
machen und die sind zwar später mit
sirup getränkt aber nicht dass ihr jetzt
denkt die sind viel zu süß also so süß
sind sie wirklich nicht man kann den
sirup natürlich auch weglassen aber dann
fehlt auf jeden fall die süße ich werde
zuerst einmal die pfannkuchen
vorbereiten und zeigt euch da mal kurz
die zutaten für den teig brauche ich 350
gramm mehl 300 milliliter heißes wasser
300 milliliter milch 60 gramm zucker
nein halben teelöffel trockenhefe einen
teelöffel backpulver und ein viertel
teelöffel salz zuerst nämlich jetzt das
mähen und gibt es in der große
rührschüssel ihr braucht es dafür auch
keine küchenmaschine das geht alles ohne
und da kommen jetzt die restlichen
trockenen zutaten mit rein also zucker
backpulver hefe und das salz das wird
jetzt kurz miteinander verrührt dann
verbinden sich die zutaten sehr gut und
es sitzt auch sowieso ein klassischer
pfannkuchenteig nur eben ohne ein
jetzt kommt die milch mit dem wasser
zusammen und dann nehme ich immer heißes
wasser und kann dann einfach direkt die
mittel aus dem kühlschrank nehmen da
muss man nämlich nicht vorher erhitzen
das kommt hier nicht rein dann wird es
jetzt schön klümpchen frei verrührt
der teig ist jetzt schon fertig da geht
wirklich super schnell den muss jetzt
allerdings nachholen lassen und dafür ab
dann stelle ich in zehn minuten zur
seite und kann in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die füllung vorbereiten für die
füllung wird normalerweise sondern ganz
traditionelle milch gräben gemacht die
wird wie so ein pudding eingekocht und
ich werde heute aber zwei varianten
machen einmal die klassische originale
variante und einmal eine mit seiner
krise schokoladen füllung und da vorne
zeige ich euch christi zutaten für die
milch füllung brauche ich 150 milliliter
milch 100 milliliter sahne 30 gramm
stärker 20 gramm zucker eine prise salz
35 gramm butter
ich brauche man extrakt rosenwasser und
eine bio orange und für die gries creme
brauche ich auch diese drei zutaten
wandel extrakt rosenwasser und eine bi
orange 250 milliliter milch 50 gramm
krise habe ich jetzt einen weichweizen
gries 20 gramm zucker 12 gramm
kakaopulver 125 gramm mascarpone und
eine prise sand bei den zutaten mengen
ist es jetzt so eine creme reicht jetzt
jeweils für die hälfte der pfannkuchen
also falls jetzt nur eine variante
machen wird zum beispiel die milch creme
müsst ihr da einfach die doppelte menge
nehmen damit es für diese pfannkuchen
menge reicht das werde ich zu als die
mädels creme machen
dafür gebe ich milch und sahne in einem
kleinen topf da kommt direkt manila
extrakt mit dazu und da sind halt die
aromen ganz wichtig also wenn jetzt nur
die milch macht ohne aromen dann
schmeckt halt sehr neutral
deswegen nehme ich jetzt noch etwas
orangenschale da müsst ihr auf jeden
fall eine bio orangen nehmen und ist
nämlich hier die hälfte und später für
die andere creme auch die hälfte was man
auch nehmen kann ist zum beispiel
orangen blüten wasser
aber das findet man wirklich nur ganz
schwer das gibt es zum beispiel den
arabischen geschätzten die geht's meist
in großen städten
aber ich finde orangen schade passt
genauso gut davon
was ich jetzt hier auch verwende ist
rosenwasser das habe ich jetzt auch aus
einem türkischen supermarkt das gibt es
aber auch in arabischen supermärkten zum
beispiel und da muss man nur darauf
achten dass es zum verzehr geeignet ist
und da gebe ich jetzt einfach nach
geschmack dazu bei mir sind jetzt etwa
zwei esslöffel müsste einfach mal
probieren es schmeckt dann auf jeden
fall sehr orientalisch es kommt noch die
restlichen zutaten mit rein also stärke
zucker und dann wird es jetzt erst mal
verrührt und zu einem pudding gebracht
als jetzt auf höchster stufe erhitzen
und einmal aufkochen lassen und dann
später putting
sobald der pudding eingedeckt ist kommt
noch das salz mit dazu das hebt einfach
nochmal den süßen geschmack und dann
gebe ich auch die butter mit rein und
zieht den pudding com herunter und die
butter sorgt dafür dass die creme später
schön streich wie ich noch sprit fähig
wird damit so eine art butter kriegen
wenn die jetzt nämlich flüssig wird ist
die creme schön weich und später im
kühlschrank witze dann wieder fest
die creme ist jetzt erst mal fertig die
decke ich jetzt ab und lasst sie
abkühlen und werde jetzt die zweite
creme zu bereiten dafür gebe ich jetzt
auch wieder milch in einen kleinen job
da comdirect das salz nicht dazu dann
auch der zugriff und das kakaopulver und
das las jetzt kurz aufkochen
jetzt kann ich an der stelle auch schon
mal vanille extrakt zufügen
wer möchte kann auch hier etwas
rosenwasser mit dazugeben und auch
orangenschale
sobald die schoko milch aufgekocht ist
kommt der gries mit dazu und dann liegt
es gleich auch ein
und nachdem sie ein paar sekunden kochen
durfte man sieht es auch an diesem see
ziehen die dann so hoch steigen kann man
den herd ausschalten und die creme
mustern erstmal abkühlen bevor die
mascarpone mit eingeführt wird
und während die krebs abkühlen kann ich
jetzt schon mal die pics aus wacken
ich arbeite sind zwei pfannen dann jetzt
wirklich unglaublich schnell die
füllungen sind ja schon vorbereitet der
teig ist vorbereitet und das auspacken
geht jetzt auch sehr schnell
die panne habe ich jetzt bereits erhöht
diesen auf mittlere stufe gestellt und
jetzt spricht ganz wenig wachstum spray
rein da braucht man sich nur ganz wenig
fett vor allem wir mal verzichtete
pfarrern hat und dann arbeite ich mit
einem eis portionierer und setzte jetzt
immer ganz kleine pen-clubs reich
alternativ kann man natürlich auch ein
esslöffel nehmen
hier an der oberfläche sieht man jetzt
dass ich ganz kleine bläschen bilden das
kommt jetzt durch die hefe zustande
und sobald der teig jetzt an der
oberfläche nicht mehr wo ist das erkennt
man einfach daran dass er nicht mehr
feucht ist können wir die pfannkuchen
rausnehmen
die werden nämlich nur an einer seite
gebacken
jetzt habe ich alle pfannkuchen gebacken
zum abkühlen habe ich sie einfach auf
einem kuchengitter gelegt die füllungen
sind vorbereitet jetzt will auch der
zucker sirup und für den zuckersirup
brauche ich ein glas zucker ein halbes
glas wasser und etwas zitronensaft
es kommt jetzt einfach eben eine top
also zucker und wasser
dann wird es zu einem super sirup
aufgekocht
sobald die zuckerwasser mischung kocht
kann ich jetzt auch zitronensaft
dazugeben und zwar sorgt der
zitronensaft dafür dass es eben nicht
kristallisiert jetzt noch kurz berührt
und dann ist der zero fertig und kann
bereits abkühlen
bevor ich die ab jetzt befülle werde ich
zuerst mal den krokant herstellen ganz
traditionell werden sie mit pistazien
bestreut
das mache ich natürlich auch aber die
schoko variante möchte ich gerne mit
krokant bestreuen und dafür habe ich
jetzt hier vorne drei zutaten und zwar
100 gramm gehackte mandeln 100 gramm
zucker und einen teelöffel butter kommt
direkt der zucker in einer pfanne den
zucker dass ich jetzt auflösen als
erhitze die pfanne
also sobald der zucker so ein bisschen
karamellisiert schalte ich meist auch
den herz aus denn die reste für die
reicht schon aus münster nämlich
aufpassen dass es nicht verbrennt jetzt
kommt direkt die butter mit rein das ist
so ein bisschen
sobald die butter aufgelöst ist gebe ich
noch die mandeln mit jetzt gut rühren
damit sich mandeln und karamell gut
verbinden kann ich den herd auch nochmal
an machen
sobald bekannt die richtige farbe
nämlich goldbraun nehme ich ihn aus der
pfanne heraus direkt auf dem backpapier
ihr könnt beim krokant auf zwei arten
übrigens vorgehen entweder zuerst die
mandeln in die pfanne
die ein bisschen an rüsten und dann
zucker drüberstreuen oder so wie ich es
gemacht habe zuerst ein karamell
darstellen und dann die mandel mit ab so
jetzt verbreitet es hier dann wird es
nicht schneller kühlen einfach glatt
streichen
jetzt lasse ich sie einfach kurz
abkühlen
jetzt kann ich die füllung und fertig
stellen die eine helle füllung war schon
fertig die habe ich jetzt noch kurz
durch gerührt und führen sie direkt in
einen spritzbeutel der mit dem
spritzbeutel lassen sich die abwässer
befüllen und das vorne habe ich so eine
kleine loch thüle mit dabei die
schokofüllung muss ich jetzt noch
fertigstellen
dafür nehme ich jetzt themas patrone und
verrühren sie dann wird sie nämlich
glatt und weich
und darüber jetzt noch diesen
grießpudding 1
jetzt ist es soweit und jetzt werden die
ad aisch geformt und zwar wurden
deswegen die pfannkuchen auch noch auf
einer seite gebacken
damit die andere seite noch übrig bleibt
und zwar drückt ihr die jetzt mit den
fingern zusammen und zwar nur bis zur
hälfte und die eine hälfte bleibt dann
offen und damit die besser
zusammenhalten müsst ihr sie übrigens
beim abkühlen abdecken damit sie nicht
austrocknen
falls euch doch austrocknen ein bisschen
wasser und befeuchtet es einfach noch
mal kurz
jetzt kann ich sie direkt ist falls ihr
jetzt einen spritzbeutel mit so einer
noch schüler habt könnt ihr auch einfach
einen gefrierbeutel zum beispiel nehmen
jetzt erst hinten reindrücken und dann
nach vorne so ein bisschen ab stehen
lassen
jetzt muss nur noch der co kann
zerkleinert werden das mache ich jetzt
hier in der küchenmaschine falls ihr
keine küchenmaschine hat könnte den
brand in einem gefrierbeutel stecken und
mit dem ausbau starb drüber rollen
und jetzt müssen die teile nur noch im
chor kann bzw
pistazien getaucht werden das macht mir
ganz vorsichtig da bekommt man eben noch
mal so diesen crunch mit dazu und
natürlich auch viel mehr geschmack
dann setze ich sie auf eine platte und
da sind sie fast schon fertig
jetzt in die arbeit fertig ich habs
jetzt hier einmal auf sondern
orientalischen teller angerichtet
oder man hier auf seiner platte ich
finde beides sehr schön aber so kann man
sie noch nicht sagen man sollte auf
jeden fall den zuckersirup noch mit dazu
geben denn die akkus sind jetzt noch
nicht süß genug als sie schmecken zwar
jetzt auch schon gut aber da zuckersirup
runde das ganze nochmal ab und so ein
super sirup das schließlich auch richtig
typisch für so orientalische arabische
gerichte vor allem und das gebe ich dir
jetzt mit drauf und bei sarkozy weil sie
nichts anderes können sie sich ganz ganz
extrem deutschen raum aber natürlich
wenn ihr zum beispiel jemanden habt der
das eben nicht mit zuckersirup markt
kann man es auch natürlich so servieren
richtig schön
ich finde es halt richtig dekorativ aus
zwar noch mit dieser variante mit schoko
und den teller hammer übrigens aus dem
urlaub geschmuggelt denn die schmucken
dort gekauft in der türkei warst du
direkt probieren ja sorgen die lakers
genau ist sally hat genau das ist sally
art als er mit krokant und schoko und
hier die traditionelle art mit diesem
mit pudding und mit irgendwas von
glückskeksen und an universe von aber
auf jeden fall ist es ein fingerfood
also bitte kein besteck dazu reichen
sondern das ist man einfach mit den
fingern
ich hoffe natürlich kam auch noch
bisschen mehr sirup nehmen mal schauen
ob es dem könig schmeckt gestürzte könig
als sehr schön vor allem kann das gut
vorbereiten und so im kühlschrank lagern
und kurz vor dem servieren könnt ihr
dann zum beispiel diesen sirup darüber
geben oder auch natürlich schon vorher
aber man ist sie auf jeden fall kalt aus
dem kühlschrank
was sagt der könig dazu der könig ist
begeistert ich finde vor allem die
kombination mit rosenwasser orangen und
dann die pistazien oder mit schokolade
wirklich sehr mit weggehauen ohne uns zu
zeigen also schon mal ab und zeigt jetzt
in die kameras ich mache also mir
gefällt beides möchte ich mich jetzt das
trikot von verlagen steckt sich das ding
also fällt beides möchte ich mich
entscheiden zwischen pistazie und
schokolade würde ich mich eher für die
schokolade obwohl es jetzt unsere kräfte
und ja weil mich die piste kostet 80
gramm 25 euro ja gut dass er natürlich
schwäbische gründe genau welche einzige
grund warum mich dafür entscheiden würde
sogar aus kostengründen ja aber wirklich
lecker ganz nah ich finde auch total
lecker ich finde vor allem könnte man
das auch zum beispiel mal vorbereiten
für eine hochzeit oder ich meine da holt
mal seine freundinnen kann das schon
vorbereiten auch ein paar tage vorher
und hat ein hübsches dessert ich hier
aufgehoben
ja ich weiß auf jeden fall findet ihre
rezepte nachmachen opfer ließen blog.de
die elite will jetzt auch gleich ins
bett und falls ihr es nach macht würde
ich mich natürlich über fotos freuen auf
facebook oder auf instagram markiert uns
weilt da wir schauen uns auf jeden fall
an
also viel spaß beim nachhaken und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder hat es
dann wieso fotos die sonne es nachmachen
und schicken aber dann bietet ihnen
diese hatte mit pistazien beschwert sich
ja jetzt schon dass du immer so viel
essen muss ja auch heute schon lange
das machen staatsexamen wieder genau das
ist das neue gold also bis zum nächsten
mal
gut dass ich nie ernst nehmen